recently for and costly teleconferencing
systems have been released by free or
inexpensive web services okay so let's
pause voice is about again this is about
the Olympics international company
across all kinds of different major
cities in different time zones different
continents and they were going to use
teleconferencing in order to do their
business together right so we're
investigating that looking at the
hardware that was required getting
frustrated the fact that two-thirds of
you forgot to mention software as an
important part of the information
technology and so on okay but now till
the last bit and this actually this is a
full marks okay and i don't i don't
think anyone got four I don't think for
a memory and here's why okay let's
unpack the question for [ __ ] and costly
teleconference decisions now I think
people missed that I think people missed
that usually teleconferencing is this
big expensive thing you have to get a
whole system installed and proper
training and it's a it's a formal system
as opposed to kind of like an ad hoc hey
let me just send out send a hangout
request to you or something like that
it's a big deal usually okay now those
have been sort of replaced in many ways
by these really cheap web services so
all of these here from be either cheap
or free okay I have a cheap or free now
there was the first missed opportunity
he was the sector 1 i'll discuss that
was ok but discuss his new trend with
regard to ok new possibilities and risks
ok pause now I think usually you see the
word discuss and you automatically go
down ok advantages disadvantages or
benefits and well let's see negatives
and that kind of thing ok so what
happened was people started to re answer
this question they looked at this and
they thought okay yeah good stuff about
teleconferencing and bad stuff about
teleconferencing and so you started
answering question a again and some of
you in fact I think I caught like two or
three of you who were taking your ads or
from a verbatim and putting them again
in c ok now that's just I don't know if
you thought when you're going to read
you like sweet if we did the same
question twice I can you know one answer
and get double asked for it that should
be a warning sort of scienter you that
you've missed they're totally different
keywords the situation that's being
looked at is quite different okay so
let's come back and see what we're
actually being asked possibilities add
risks for who commercial users now
what's a commercial user will be the
opposite of a commercial user you guys
okay so so students why why can't
students be commercial users yeah yeah
good so commercial right it's arm to
earn money right to earn revenue so the
opposite to a commercial user we would
tend to call a personal user ok so like
personal computers right um so there was
the first thing that you missed ok so we
sort of answered in general terms and
didn't talk about people who try and
make money off this thing ok secondly
though people often talked about the
companies that are producing
teleconferencing systems right so you
talked about skype and Apple and
Facebook and Google versus all these
companies who used to be making
teleconference system systems and so on
ok so you might have said are there's
going to be heaps of competition in this
space now that people are introducing a
free product and you didn't talk about
the company's for commercial users who
are actually going to be using Skype
FaceTime Facebook and so on to actually
do video calling ok so that's why so few
people got full marks because you just
you might have given me a lot of valid
information but you just miss the
question entirely ok so that's what
you've got to use reading time for right
ok so now that you feel really guilty
for not getting the question let me show
you how he should answer this ok so if
you've got your notes there um you can
just head it benefits and risks that
would have worked
ok so I think this was four months so
it's kind of looking for two and two
right just generally speaking but let me
give you I feel about six here right
sure number one and some of these are
really obvious but you didn't phrase it
the right way or you like I said you
missed the question so here's one an
increase in remote and international
work that's a new arm sorry I didn't
mean benefits I mean opportunities and
increase opportunity to where it was
Impractical before because you need to
take flights or just in at the time or
the money to set up an office elsewhere
now you can do international or remote
work much more easily small companies
startups ones without massive budgets
can become international companies quite
more relatively easily compared two days
of the past where you need to have
millions maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars to actually be an international
company okay so the fact that you can
cross physical and chronological
boundaries opens up this possibility
this opportunity okay that makes sense
you see I'm trying to answer the
question it's about commercial users so
I'm thinking business in terms of not
just we're here I can chat to my my
grandma across the other side of the
world that's useful and does it into the
question okay so that's what I'm
thinking about business yeah commercial
okay another one you can replace
expensive setups these formal and costly
systems that I was talking about before
with really really simple kinds of our
hardware and when you're answering
question be all of this stuff there was
very very cheap you like you guys could
afford it right so if you replace those
kinds of expensive setups and also
expensive contracts so you know making
international calls on say a telephone
it costs a lot of money right like they
didn't charge you you don't just pick up
the phone and you make a call it is
tweet sense or even a dollar right
they charge you by the minute right
that's very very costly but you know
you're not people who are on a Google+
Hangout or on skype they're not like
watching their seconds countdown okay so
you're replacing expensive setups and
expensive ongoing costs with a really
really cheap system and again not using
the word cheap as in like ah you know
kind of a bit dodgy right but cheap for
a business that's really really good
right it opens up a whole bunch of
opportunities okay atmos right now this
was kind of a sort of what's what I'm
looking for alluded to in in part a okay
but their ability to call emergency
meetings that's important for a company
and really really useful okay the
ability to not have to schedule a
meeting but up Oh something's going
wrong our servers gone down in this
country or there's a disaster or
something we have to respond to its time
critical okay teleconference he allows
you to call these kinds of things for
international offices that's really cool
that's a business thing in days past
even if you were international company
right you would have had your meeting
scheduled before we talked about this in
part a okay so if there was some kind of
disaster some kind of emergency that
require quick response you just had to
wait to the next business day to
actually take any action on it or maybe
later in the week even because you had
to fly over there and so on okay I even
got a I I've got a cousin my my dad's
oldest sister's son and my dad's
actually the youngest in his family so
he's like this this cousin of mine is
like 25 years older than me so so
there's a big gap wreck but he's part of
an international important company so
they import foods and that kind of thing
of the key frozen so on but they don't
do this kind of thing right they have to
travel back and forth between Australia
Malaysia Singapore all of these
Southeast Asian country
because that's where all the importing
is happening okay so we need they need
to have a meeting it's not going to be
an emergency mean they just don't do
that kind of thing okay because they
don't have these kinds of systems in
place okay a fourth and last sort of and
this this one was very sort of rare I
think maybe one or two people mentioned
it but one of the cool things about say
you know Google Plus hangouts is the
main place that this is happening okay
but it's not just for the company to
interact with itself okay have you
noticed companies or like politicians in
that company doing Google+ has as a way
of engaging with the public okay so
President Obama did a really big one so
this year I think it was earlier this
year you can go look it up okay because
on YouTube now they did the Hangout
their record it and it's it's available
for everyone so what it allows for what
it enables is engagement with the public
in a really substantive way okay how
would a comforter usually interact with
its audience or with its clients okay
generally quite impersonal ways like
sending out letters to its customers or
pretty an ad on TV something like that
it's a lot customers it's not to your
way really it's quite it's quite simplex
isn't it right so this is really really
cool this is a big quantum leap up and
that's why so many people like
politicians and other big companies i
use you okay so there are some new
opportunities right now can you see how
opportunities is very very different
here's our list to benefits right they
do over the lab but these are like not
just I this is good but this is hey look
at all this cool new stuff which we can
never could do before was Impractical
before and now we have the opportunity
to go and do it does that make sense
yeah yeah okay
I'll tell me what its risks okay now
again people were really exaggerating
with their risks okay so they said
things like oh no the the whole universe
is going to find out all of our stuff
that you know all of our what's the
phrase I'm looking for all about data
that we've put online because it's all
public in that kind of thing yeah I
think that's a bit of an exaggeration
okay but there are some privacy concerns
okay so let's have a look I've got a
couple if you said if you set lack of
security that was okay as long as you
didn't go over the top okay so what
might be examples of lack of security
what could really happen any thoughts
practically speaking
yeah Sonny
okay here good so maybe not necessarily
like totally listen here but if you've
got people who leave their accounts
logged in which by the way in companies
happens all the time that's a real
that's a real security risk okay so for
example authorized accounts being
misused okay I'm this heaps of kinds of
security practices which we all know
about like don't leave stuff love you
change your passwords often all that
kind of thing which is very obvious they
kind of truisms but people still don't
do them because they're inconvenient
okay so you open yourself up to I'm
security risks there you've also got the
problem of this is kind of related okay
not just authorized accounts being
misused but authorized accounts that's a
that's a nurse really matters not just
being like hijacked by someone else who
just walks along and all someone's left
himself logged you you know which
happens to people's facebook accounts
all the time but authorized accounts
being maliciously misused right remember
we distinguish between those so this is
the actual person who owns this account
but they're actually going to purposely
use it for the wrong purpose okay so
things like I'm trying to think of if
you're a an owner or an administrator in
one of these companies okay you're an
authorized user who has access to all
this data is passing through your
company it passes through facebook or
skype or through apple and so on past us
through their servers okay so you have
people who authorized they have
authorized the counts okay but they can
misuse it and they can actually listen
in so that's very different to some
random guy coming in and trying to hack
someone's account okay this is someone
on the inside okay from the from the
video conferencing companies in
okay so this is why it's a different
risk is from different people okay so
this is what we really mean by these are
these are dangerous if a company was
going to say go with these companies and
get rid of it's a it's big extensive
teleconferencing system these are the
things that have to judge it a is this
worth like the operational feasibility
benefits and the economic feasibility
zabila tea benefits is it worth it for
the for the risks that we incur okay
that makes sense so just to summarize
again I think the big thing that you
missed was that most people weren't
thinking business minded they weren't
they missed the point that it was about
commercial users okay which is why you
miss the question okay yeah yeah okay
yeah sure all right I think I think
that's a fair mature so it's kind of
like the flip side of this one sorry I
keep number three yeah I don't know if
it's necessarily such a like I don't
think it's necessarily the best thing i
would have paid it but i don't think
it's the best answer because there's a
company I'm not thinking I'm opening
myself up to this because it's a tool
that I'm going to use right so maybe an
individual worker might be like oh I
don't want to work here because they use
this system but